cuando participamos en juegos de azar a
veces tenemos la sensación de que
estamos en desventaja o de que el juego
no fue justo y por eso perdimos
averigüemos en qué caso solo fue el azar
que no nos favoreció pero que el juego
si era justo vamos a jugar con estas
monedas especiales que en una cara
tienen un cero y en la otra un 1
al lanzar una de estas maneras hay dos
posibles resultados que caiga cero o que
caiga uno así que cuando el resultado
sea cero tú ganas y cuando sea uno yo
gano el juego parece bastante justo
cada uno tiene una posibilidad de ganar
porque son dos resultados posibles así
que estamos parejos te propongo que
sigamos jugando pero ahora con dos de
estas monedas si la suma de los dos
números que salgan es cero ganas tu
filas un mes uno gano yo y si la suma es
dos ninguna gana es bastante justo
analicemos si realmente se dio un juego
en donde tenemos las mismas
probabilidades de ganar en esta tabla
tenemos los resultados posibles el 0 y
el 1 de arriba serán para la manera 1 y
los de la izquierda para la moneda 2
los cuadros donde se cruza cada uno
representan los resultados en donde se
cruza el 0 y el 0 el total será 0 y es
con el que tú ganas cuando caiga 1 en la
moneda 1 y 0 en la otra
el resultado es 1 al igual que el 1 para
la moneda 2 y el 0 en la moneda 1 en
ambos casos ganaría yo al tener como
total el 1
y cuando ambas monedas caigan de lado
uno sumarán dos y nadie gana de las
cuatro posibilidades que hay para las
dos monedas una te hace ganar a ti dos
me hacen ganar a mí y una a nadie así
que yo tengo el doble de posibilidades
de ganar y eso no es justo pero podemos
replantear el juego con la información
que ya tenemos lo que necesitamos para
un juego justo es que las probabilidades
de ganar sean las mismas para todos
cuando esto ocurre se dice que los
resultados son x probables cómo está
nuestro juego no son x probables lo más
sencillo es juntar los resultados del 0
y del 2 para una persona y los del 1
para la otra así tú ganas con los
resultados 0 y 2 y yo cuando el
resultado sea 1
el juego ya es justo porque cada uno
tiene dos de cuatro posibilidades de
ganar otra manera de hacer equipo
probable el juego sería considerar que
se ganen puntos teniendo la primera
asignación donde tú ganas con el cero y
yo con el uno que tal que llega en un
punto y tú dos al tener la mitad de las
posibilidades se compensa con el doble
de premio y vuelve a ser un juego justo
te explico lo anterior
suponiendo que una ronda de 4 tiros
resultará exactamente como la tabla lo
indica saldría una vez el 0 2 veces 1 y
una vez el 2 el 0 se premiaría con 2
puntos y el 1 con un punto
como el 0 sale una vez quién tenga ese
número tendrá 2 puntos y quien tenga el
1 al resultar dos veces ganador también
tendría 2 puntos por eso es x probable
porque es justo que el que tenga menos
posibilidades de ganar gane más puntos
para compensar
recuerda que es un juego de azar y que
puede que el resultado varíe pero en
teoría las posibilidades son iguales
ajustamos un juego de dos formas
diferentes para que fuera justo puedes
descubrir más y adaptarlas de diferentes
situaciones con azar para que todo
dependa de la suerte y no de la
probabilidad